-Welcome, welcome, welcome t
"The Tonight Show", everybody.
You're here. Thank you
for watching.
Well, guys, we are coming to you
after the Olympic
opening ceremony right now
And the ceremony had everythin
you could possibly want --
music, dancing, fireworks,
and the show-stopper,
a greased-up flag-bearer
from Tonga.
-And here comes Tonga, perhaps
the only Olympic nation
made famous for its
flag-bearing.
-Yeah.
-That baby oil is
the first good PR
Johnson & Johnson has
had in a year.
I just -- I'm sorry.
Yep, everyone loved it until h
got too close
to the Olympic torch.
Like, "Oh, fire in the hole!
Get him away, get him away!"
That's right, the Tokyo Olympics
are finally here,
but you could tell the ceremon
was delayed a year
when they said, "Release the
doves."
Oh, no.
Okay. Cut to Tonga,
cut to Tonga. [ Clears throat
Cut to Tonga. Yeah.
And a lot of people are talkin
about Italy's outfits.
Take a -- Take a look at these
Yeah.
Look like a bunch of Sbarr
workers going on strike.
Come on, Italy. You're in Japan,
the birth place of Nintendo.
How can you not bust out
the Mario and Luigi overalls
I mean, come on.
At one point, a few performers
came out
and did live reenactments
of all 50 Olympic sport logos.
Watch this.
♪♪♪♪
When you have three hours to
fill with no crowd,
this is what you end up with
Ladies and gentlemen,
that's what happened.
That's right.
Over the next two weeks,
we'll see 339 different events
Of course, one popular sport i
trampoline.
It's not -- really not what yo
think it is.
Take a look.
-If he makes better than
61,745,
he'll take gold for China.
-Okay, it's exactly what you
think it is.
No big deal. All right.
Um...
-[ Laughs ]
-But this isn't good --
an Australia equestrian athlet
was suspended
for a positive cocaine test.
Organizers knew something was up
when he jumped seven fence
during practice and --
and he wasn't on a horse.
And he goes.
Some sports news here in
the U.S. --
today, Cleveland announced
they're changing the name
of their baseball team to
the Cleveland Guardians.
Come on, even the name
Washington Football Team
is more exciting than that
I'm surprised they didn't go
with something more unique
to Cleveland, like The Layovers,
or...
We Miss Lebrons. You know?
People aren't wild about
their new logo either.
Here, look at the logo.
Oh.
Looks like Thor's helmet hooke
up with Mr. Mets.
So, this is big, too --
the NFL announced that
this season,
teams will automatically forfeit
games that are delayed
by a COVID outbreak.
Yup, the teams will have t
forfeit or worse,
change their names to
The Guardians.
Some business news -- I saw that
Walmart is offering
free health screenings to
customers starting tomorrow.
Meanwhile, one guy getting
his prostate checked
at Walmart today is like,
"What do you mean,
'starting tomorrow'?
Who are you?"
Yeah, I have cash.
And finally, I read about a mo
who threw her 6-year-old son
a Southwest Airlines-theme
birthday party.
His mom really nailed the theme,
because every kid went hom
with four ounces of water an
a bag of old potato chips.